everything that we do to the public and
I and Anson Mills really didn't have a
public until maybe three or four years
ago we just couldn't get enough
resources into that direction and when
you're talking about we're supplying the
best chefs around the world that's not
really the public the chefs have the air
the public so in in our pursuit of our
cultural responsibility we have slowly
but surely begun to build a lot of
people would say why didn't you write
the book and the answer is I don't have
enough broad concept experience to write
a book yet but we are saying what I
think I hope is the truth about what
we're doing very very slowly at Anson
Mills calm and we're being very careful
to knit it together culturally it is a
cultural exercise there it is not a
sales vehicle it is not so that we can
package up little units and send them to
the public it's a cultural vehicle and
when you go there you're going to note
that it is calm and it has deep
authenticity and as we move forward the
chaotic stream of products that if you
clicked on the wholesale product side
and could imagine what the cultural
documentation would be for the some 200
different arcane products that even most
chefs in America haven't heard of when
you think about the fact that that's
going to come down get filtered by a
very carefully edited view so that what
we're presenting if you say I don't
understand that you actually can get a
cogent and simple answer that has
cultural meaning that's where we're
going with Anson Mills calm but in my
opinion it's very much there we've had
to now
Awards because of it just recently and
we have more on the way I don't think we
use those as mile markers for our
success this way but i think that the
responsibility we have would be to say
what we are presenting is a land race
cuisine that belongs to the culture of
the region in which we're farming and it
has belonged to the culture no matter
what diasporas affected it since the
beginning of settlement and before the
south is one of the very few places in
the united states were a broadly popular
food way the history of a certain food
shows through pre first contact or
pre-columbian we have pre-columbian
foods on the table and they are no
different than what Native Americans
were eating when the first settlers
showed up and we have a lot to do with
seedsman with a few nation to kind of
stay connected at anson Milson through
the foundation as well and i think that
the food then has to show through as a
whole body of cuisine and that is the
culture of the food if you're just
focused on heirloom tomatoes squashes
and things like that which is great what
sort of cuisine are they supposed to be
tied to why are you doing that in your
garden besides the fact that a beautiful
tomato is beautiful there's a higher
meaning to the tomato besides the fact
that you have a tomato that should be
gone that's still here and thank God and
it tastes great so what do you do with
it really besides eat it that's a good
celebration that's the first one but
what was it originally how did it arrive
at being so terrific what was the food
what was the perception of the cuisine
or the food or the foods of the culture
in which the tomato evolved to become so
fast so glorious so our responsibility
would be to bring the culture of our
local farming forward in its food and
the paradigm then says sustainability
flavor
reservation survival nutrition culture
begins at the table goes to the farm
it's not farm-to-table it's table to
farm as soon as you get past the
American depression the 1930s its table
to farm not the other way around
I think that the idea of bringing
together the sort of monoculture that is
just so pervasive the idea that pizza is
the most popular food in America is a
good example of what can happen in the
south and I guess I shouldn't say
anything without pointing to a gent
named John T edge who actually really no
kidding gets it and worries about the
disappearance of the bread that makes po
boys in New Orleans worries about the
disappearance of pickles and the way
they're done in a certain place it all
placed based specific cultural
interpretations of fundamental
ingredients wheat in New Orleans but we
don't think about that we don't think
about ploy in New Orleans PL o ye s
which is a CREP which is straight from
Brittany and the northern part of Spain
and in was Acadian we don't think about
how those things knit together in
southern foods in fact I would grant you
that probably ninety nine out of a
hundred people who are fascinated with
cuisine have never even heard the idea
that crepes made from buckwheat in
Louisiana are really popular you know
that's something that we worry about it
going away you know why crepes made from
buckwheat are popular you have to grow
buckwheat in order to grow corn or your
fields go down if you don't have
synthetic nitrogen so the those place
based foods have agricultural meaning
but then they have this glorious
evolution into terrific food that's
sustaining as well and i think that the
threat then would be that we lose the
fine points what people would call the
kind of arcania out there the little
teeny things that have to do with
southern food and its culture and then
how to apply that same idea to the other
regions in this country and then in
Mexico where the taco areas are being
taken over by instant masa and it's rare
even here on
in New York right now in New York City
it's rare with our great big Latin
influence here to find anyone doing
fresh masa on a human scale it's really
hard you can see them doing it on a
production scale but who's making mas at
home anymore this is something that
everyone used to do the ash bucket under
the roof drain making would lie potash
and then drop in grain corn good one
beans go into if you want but driving
coin you and you make a vital and
important nutritional transformation of
food right and I worry about the hand
processes being gone even with the
current let's do it all in our garden
thing I worried that that won't be
sustained so it's the smaller points
where we may even have the food so no
tortillas aren't threatened well they're
not you know well maybe they are you
know who knows how to make them you need
a machine that sort of thing